Fall Guys right Fall Guys yeah Fall Guys
Fall Guys shot ultimate guys ultimate
dudes all of the dudes why am I Fall Guy
8211 what does that mean I I'm a number
as well I have no
[Music]
idea
I'm so surprised you can basically make
your steam name anything you want
because like obviously there's huge
problems with that what do you mean what
are you talking about I don't know you
could make your steam name
clicker or dick hole
oring eater I don't know maybe any of
those might be problematic to have as
publicly displayed in a game for
children of problematic names before I
can make a judgment you could call
yourself the
giant all right you could be the slimy
head uhhuh uhhuh you could be the sh
eating looking [__] oh I didn't mute
that one ah damn it the bits over I said
I said it damn I'm in the very back as
far as I recall that's not the place to
be I'm always in toward the back the
back is definitely wrong way Mark never
mind mark
thanks man good job Mark I made it thank
you get out of my way I went the wrong
way oh my God I got hit oh no that's not
you don't you hate to see
this oh my God I got bounced
over Mark I'm behind you oh good oh no
what
theing now I'm fifth who's grabbing me
who grabbed me I'm just getting hitting
you with the grabby hands was that you
and the pineapple there grabbing you no
I'm not the pineapple I was just
watching there's there's a gap at the
end Gap watch out there's a gap there's
a gap Oh you mean yeah you have to jump
that one buddy that was a gap oh no we
can't find each other because the no
names man I really wish you could just
observe your partyes we'll have to learn
what we're wearing and and just know
know the truth I think I'm pretty
obvious that's true could I'll just go
as default default boys I am the only
def defitely can see
you see by being default I am unique all
of you jerk person on this entire server
has left themel oh no there's green
default guy okay okay that's fair that's
fair all right all right one other
person is as big brain as Mark is thank
you thank you thank you is it me no oh
what the heck out Rising slime survive
three each okay oh this one's like a
classic like Wipeout Course like the TV
show if you go too slow the Slime
consumes you okay that's not good you
got to not let it touch you okay but
it's just like a it's like it's fun this
is a fun one man I I feel I feel like
I'm at a disadvantage cuz it keep having
to sight read all of these you're I mean
the general prefaces oh you got an arrow
over your head I see you guys a little
arrow oh hey I see I see you right now
with the arrow God God oh God oh good
lord oh my good how are you in the front
of the pack Mark I don't know man I feel
like I'm at a disadvantage this was an
error get off of me oh you can't okay I
thought I might be able to Oh I thought
I might be able to sneak that one but
turns out touching me oh God oh God oh
God oh my God oh you a you a I can't
even see my own
existence all right everyone I'm not
going to hurt you you don't hurt
me no oh my God oh my God oh my God oh
my God oh my God oh my
God okay okay okay oh I need I really
need to get this done before other
people oh my God where's the Slime I
died people exist
all right guess I got very deeply and
personally Mark Mark are you just down
get into the Slime yeah wait which slime
I'm at the second you're at the balls
now yeah I'm at the balls oh c I'm
watching you okay cool you're very about
to finish complicated skin oh it bounces
oh wait did you were you like first
place waade no I got eliminated because
I got knocked in the Slime by ass I'm
about to be in fourth place unless God
hates me oh thank you okay fourth place
I'm done are you still alive Mark or you
done I finished I finished I was like
third oh you were ahead of me still
nuh-uh I don't know what to tell you man
I passed you I passed you at some point
I I don't know what to tell you man I
finished third I definitely passed you I
I don't know how to break it to you man
but I Mark I passed you listen to me
look man I don't know what to
say listen by I do I do see you do you
see me uh what are you I don't even know
what you're wearing I'm the pink unicorn
oh okay I see you I see pink up pink top
half there another unicorn but he's all
splotchy gotcha gotcha got pink unicorn
I see you okay man a lot of people got
eliminated in just those two games that
one's pretty harsh if the crowd if the
crowd gets into trouble on that one the
Slime consumes a lot of people oh no
this one's so garbage I hate this one
I've only ever finished one of these I'm
going to just go for it screw waiting
wait wait Mark oh yeah what's up it
wasn't the strategy to wait though scre
screw waiting I'm going for it Bab
I'm a champie doie I'm jeez this is the
one for me so smart so
unbelievably smart here we go shut up
I'm the best ow I'm going for
it I don't think I'm going to make it
this time guys oh no how many oh God
you're screwed screwed no it's fine this
is fine bunch of babies bunch of babies
Bunch
ah oh oh my God I got pushed into it
I literally they were trying to push me
off the edge oh my God yeah Mark did you
make it no no I didn't make it I was
hedging my bets and it didn't work out
not tail one no it's the oh my God the
Tail's so stupid all right where's Bob
there's Bob okay good moves good moves
Bob good sneaky good sneaky yeah you got
it oh dive bomb him yes oh damn it I
should have Dove yeah it's okay are you
ready for this yeah I'm so ready no
don't let go back up top
okay so good oh
freak are you ready I'm ready Bob I'm
ready okay he's coming he's going to
come up to yeah yeah yeah yeah you
coming over here you trying to come in
here oh no you're horrible eror I've Got
The Intercept You've Got The Intercept
you've got oh someone else someone
intercepted it before you did got it go
go run run
run run run run good good good excellent
excellent work watch the ball ball good
ball yes Bob
yes no no no I've made a
[Applause]
mistake son of a I hate this game mode
it sucks God damn it man that so close
so close I'm going to switch to naked
man you want to just be different naked
men colors so that it's easier to see us
yes I'm going to be the Hideous orange
nak naked man oh that is very flesh
toned that's not flesh toned what the
hell's wrong with your
flesh is that what color you are
underneath yeah you know you know how it
is all right so what color you guys be
in uh Mark's pink I'm orange you're kind
of a nice minty green I like that green
green that's onead good green oh that's
a good one now now I'm mom flushy oh
there you go that's yeah that's a keeper
all right Casper all right let's do this
I like that my face is the same color as
my rest of my whatever that is MHM you
might as well just take off the bodysuit
and just be what underneath all right so
what's our goal one win between the
three of us maybe yeah we won't stop
till we each get one win this is exactly
Most Extreme Elimination this is this is
the one oh this is totally random oh no
this is not going to be fair no just you
don't want to be in the front you want
to you want to hang right in the middle
no I'm going to go for the front all
right Mark you go for it buddy okay
buddy I'll be right behind you all right
cool oh there's two naked pink people oh
no that's okay don't worry one of us be
eliminated all right I'm in the back of
the pack right where you really want to
be Got Confidence I've Got Confidence
I've got oh crap oh crap oh why would I
have come over in your direction get out
of my way door get out of my
way this is the one got no not oh no I'm
stuck inside of all the
sausages okay okay okay I I feel oh no
God man this guy knows exactly where to
go I'm in the last place how does this
person get everyone
right yeah is it only one that opens is
it only one oh no this person's cheating
or something there's no way oh no oh no
out of my
way get get out of my way get out of my
way
everybody I think made
it oh God bye guys see
you I spectated you
by I didn't know that only one door was
going to be openable I was like I
numbers of doors open oh no as one might
expect in a game every wrong door I
tried every single time I was like oh
this one oh this one oh this one
man oh God memory M oh I hate this one
well I mean barely anyone gets
eliminated in this one
orange orange glad going to come over by
you next time push me off so we can be
buddies grap
[__] wait are you on watermelon right I
think I'm want a water I think you're
right die
losers oh that poor fell is that it are
we done yes oh yeah we did it guys oh
nice
job I think I had to move one time
during that yeah you were kind of just
in the right spot yeah I just idiots
minimal effort is my favorite way to win
oh not this oh the the key to this one
is interfering
we need to basically pick a team to
screw over actually when we played our
our we just never interfered like no one
from our team interfered well no one
interfere with us too we got lucky just
push good stick work as a team push hard
we got this yeah come on red idiots go
red oh my face I dove and the ball
didn't even budge that's okay push jump
push jump push we have a couple we have
a couple teammates who are just under
there doing work right now oh yeah go go
go go go come in come in for dive push
you're in first you're in first go to
the right got to go to the right got to
go to the right got to go to the right
yeah keep it going keep it going keep it
going keep it going you're in first
you're in first just go for it gun it is
it yeah yeah yeah yeah okay the
interference is coming work against them
work against them work work against them
oh no stop touching us we're good we're
good we're good keep going keep going
keep going keep going go go go yeah yeah
that's it that's it that's it oh no [__]
everyone is screwing us no they're
screwing blue too blue is screwed blue
is screw screwed blue is hard screwed
blue is been screwed we got blue pinned
over here just keep working ours you got
time you got time you got it all right
get it I'm pushing blue back up yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah go go go baby
go go go go go go go screw you blue we
did
it all right go Che our blistery red
testicles yeah good good yuck I kind of
regret word choice there yeah I regret
everything I regret trying to guess
doors that's what I
yeah that's no Mark you oh this one's
hard oh it's another team I've never SE
I've done this this one uh the key is to
sort of pick an area and learn where the
Rings are and just be the first one to
snatch up the Rings every time they
spawn okay oh so they got you got to
dive through them oh it's still three
teams my God okay uh Red's in the lead
go team Red's in the
lead nope oh you almost had
that mine nice nice
mine nice mine no Red's in the lead oh
no Blue's in the blue just took the lead
but that's okayed in second fine it's
fine it's fine ooh Bob you got
it yes excellent excellent don't worry
teammate I'm
here all right red is in the lead now
yes comforta are yes we are excellent
excellent excellent uh-huh excellent red
has destroyed red oh the Superman posed
at the end of the round excellent
excellent excellent excellent man you
guys went through a lot of mini games uh
Man mark this this fun yeah it's good at
least we can't possibly get another team
one for the end right 100% not not going
to happen no tail no tail no tail no
balls no tails I mean I think I still
got a
Oho this one yeah yeah yeah I am in the
dead center of the pack you not a great
place to be Destiny so I'm pretty sure I
have to jump off this orange thing or
else I fall flat on my face
probably oh don't touch me don't touch
me I'm right behind you waade I'm trying
to get through the first the first swing
what happened to my
face oh tight the balls they coming okay
all right all right I took a B in the
face definely lost now you want to see
this move Mark I do I do that is oh no I
jumped it no no no no no no no no no it
blang me ah damn it it's still purple's
there already no he's going to get it
damn it Bob you were close you were
close I I screwed it up what is the move
you were going to get a speed boost the
hammer will sometimes physics you way
the hell far forward if you're if you're
in the middle of the pack you can
sometimes get a huge random chance jump
to the front makesense that makes sense
but why why did hitting the first gate
knock me out those push do I don't know
man I don't know hey I'm like apple my
one weakness is
Gates yeah man woo connection error woo
oh no oh God okay hey what's up guys hey
you Do's play Bob back in the hob it's
Bob it's it's Fall Guys 7811 Bob FB on
FB you can watch him live on the book on
flesh book on the book flesh
book I made a harmless Ethan reference
and you called it flesh book Wade flesh
book gaming yuck is this the one we did
just before this is the this is not the
guessing door
this is the gates that go up and down
not the MC one all right good I should
be fine on this one you can tell which
one's open Mark don't run into the walls
you got sounds good sounds good sounds
good I I think it's funny I've only
played this a few times but every time
there's been someone who for the entire
session struggled to get out of the
first round and I'm a little bit afraid
it's going to be you today Mark no no
I'm fine this game is nothing get out of
my way you idiots what kind of idiots
are these guys picking the wrong doors
all the time like a bunch of dummies my
face how did you make that I don't know
oh God the only the middle ones oh my
God oh my God oh my God don't be this
way to
me oh God
no no no no no no no not like this not
like this
okay made it made it you got this Bob
where are
you okay I made it oh my yeah you made
it you made it you're good wait did you
in I was top three all right cool I was
like top whatever oh god oh I hate this
one why are we all facing the wrong way
what's wrong with us that's a good
question I don't know what we IDI these
balls are our balls hey wait blue we
want you to lose no no no blue we need
you to lose no this blue is all our ball
our ball blue why yellow why are you
even in this corner get out of here not
welcome here
oh no God nice
H get out of here how are people hitting
the ball like a th miles jump diving is
what I'm doing oh my God oh my God oh my
God get out of here get out of here get
out of here get this pigeon [__] oh
my God this one pigeon is we've got five
red teams that can't don't hit it back
you idiots oh my God they're stealing
our balls oh my God oh my God oh my God
we have no balls we have no balls I
think that's you one of you were bobber
Wade I'm with you that's yeah de I'm
over here in yellow we got red we got
Reds Reds Reds is we got them get them
keep them keep them in all right kill
the blue just grab a blue and get them
I'm not letting you do what you want to
do you get back here you little yellow
ugly oh my God Reds please Reds please
you pigeon you pigeon come here oh my
God the pigeon oh my God oh my God oh my
God oh my God oh my God oh my God oh my
God oh my God oh my God what is
happening ah no yes oh my God I'm so
useless get it back we're okay we're
okay we're okay we're F fine it's fine
it's fine it's fine it's fine
pige pigeon dicks I swear to God I was
like not working I couldn't push the
balls even when I made contact they went
nowhere I don't know man this one pigeon
had Mar like eight other people one
pigeon yeah one pigeon there was like
MVP pigeon it must be like a certain
jump angle like that gets it the right
45° what tail tag
what what is oh
no no oh but there's like a bunch of
Tails right God no no hey I started with
the tail hey I started with a tail do
you guys want to hear the Strat Mark go
to the center go to the bottom center
and run around the bottom center very
casually okay all right very cash very
cash no one no one will see us okay very
cash okay unless all of the other tail
come do this casual casual casual
someone someone's on to us okay very
casual casual touching things is bad
casual casual so casual you see how
casual we're being I had you in my grass
oh no Mark
run thank you how did how did we both
lose it in the span of like half a
second I I don't know man I don't know
oh God ow casual C no
how woo
uhoh casual so
casual oh God oh God oh God somebody
stole my my my tail
I'm using the Hammer as a defense no no
no no what the I grabbed oh God oh God
oh God no no please mark I'm really
sorry I'm really sorry Mark too so sorry
I am so sorry I need you son of a [__]
I'm so sorry I am so sorry I'm so sorry
why is everyone in this game a [__]
ninja I wonder if that's one of the game
modes people have complained about yeah
the tail one so oh
God
oh well all right we'll see good we'll
see about this one you guys [__]
ready are you freaking ready I'm not
tell me you're ready because it's about
to go
down yes yes yes to go down that's the
wayby all right I'm going for
it I believe ah sh do you ever try
paying attention to where other people
have tried oh my God oh my God man this
one's a windy
one oh they're being
babies
ow uhoh they're forging they're forging
they're for foraging they're foraging
their path you see the path see the path
I see the path oh yes yes you see the
path you see the path this definitely
the path oh my
God that was a good strategize thank you
thank you that was a brilliant strategy
thank you thank you thank you thank you
knock everyone else off and randomly
onto platforms and then use their death
to better your who who is still in the
game judgy MC Jason pants huh no it's a
good good strategy I'm that's what I do
thank you it is a good strategy I bet
it's going to be another freaking tail
one oh okay Fall Mountain all right so
what was it you did about the hammer you
did something with the hammer don't it's
a gamble the Hammers at the end might
hit you forward but they also might
screw you over all right so just try to
get you're if you're in a rough spot you
can at the end try and have the hammer
launch you forward they're like the
little spinny hammers but nice nice nice
I will win now this door I face planted
into God God oh God oh God God balls God
oh my God it's so oh where are you going
where you going balls F you're fine
you're fine fine where you going balls
there's a ball coming in right on my
head oh my God you're fine you're fine
you're fine oh my God D you're in the
lead you're in the lead in the lead keep
it clean keep it clean I keep it clean
ah didn't keep it clean God
why would you run against them look look
man look oh my god look man my dude my
man my main man this buddy can't hold it
against you look I'm I'm blue oh you're
not blue you're nice and Le now you like
a pumpy couch is that a weird thing to
say to some it's it's like a navy blue
and I appreciate your compliment Wade ah
the gamble I've seen people use these
little things to boost themselves too
the spinny dads I'm sure but man what a
risk I'll just do it normally oh why am
I in the oh you two are in the front at
least yeah hey Mark yeah hey dude let's
go buddy why am I slower than everyone
what's happening this seems
unfair man people can't no object
permanence here oh oh my God the lag is
so real on everyone getting just
absolutely FL oh you have to climb oh
you can't climb I didn't even know you
could climb that's fascinating okay
that's a new tactic there we
go oh why did you idiots in front of me
cause me problems for myself ow cuz
they're idiots they were in front of
you no that was my own
fault God this is so Center is so risky
no God oh God oh thank you I'm alive oh
my God oh my God oh my God I think I'm
in trouble I think I'm in trouble get
off of me hot dog
oh my God oh my God and yump yump
yump well this was fun oh God yeah don't
go down the center ever on the whirly
gig unless you're like in last and you
want to book it Bob you in I'm going
baby you got it uh yeah I'm got it I'm
good I'm not you got you got it yeah you
got it you got it you got it you got it
you got it hey perfect match would it be
easier if each each of us just stands on
a fruit and stays there and we
potentially yeah there's up to like five
fruits though so I got grapes grapes and
grapes got bananas bananas grapes and
bananas that's literally all it is
grapes and bananas all right teamwork
teamwork it is grapes grap grapes stay
at the
middle touch me I'm holding on for dear
life hold on St touching me okay okay
everything's fine everything fine to the
left orang you got grapes orange grap
orange grape apple I got grapes banana
okay it's banana banana that's Mark
right that's me yep there's also another
banana to our right so you're
good ping easy easy easy okay Cherry
watermelon okay I'll be on the
watermelon banana grape okay okay so we
got all five right down here I got
watermelon way up wo careful my dude uh
me oh God where's Apple I'm on Apple
right wait no I'm not am I wait oh my
God why I thought I was on Apple you
what was I on me quick there was not an
apple close to me I thought I was on are
you guys both dead
idiot barely anyone gets eliminated in
this one that was totally my fault I was
on watermelon God damn it the splitting
up of responsibilities I think was bad
cuz only because I ended up having to
rely on you for some reason made me not
think oh god oh it's okay Wade you got
good te tees probably I'll join you soon
look I get I get watermelon and apple
confused all the time they're so similar
they're so similar you're right you're
right I swear to God they stack the
yellow team with the ones they want to
lose yellow team gets picked on a lot
it's cuz yellow is such a dumb color so
stupid ID oh don't go over the humps oh
we're in last already go You Blue
[__] oh
no oh no oh god oh no you're all bumping
against each other oh no God oh my God
wait wait you you overtook blue you're
ahead of blue you're ahead of blue Mar
Oh I thought you were yellow no oh uh
yeah no you're in trouble go faster we
took ourselves by a large
margin you're beating yourselves where
did all your people go your team is
trying to ruin your team's trying to
ruin everything else they've got red
held up
completely face go go wait you're you're
overtaking yourself now or whatever I
thing Red's not here to ruin get out of
here he a pigeon the red one's not
moving so the blue one's not moving
either man oh no the red is breaking out
oh dear oh that that might be the game
oh your team is scrambling but the red
team is smarter than they are better
than they are oh yeah they sure are they
sure they really are they're really they
really fine we're definitely moving now
well someone grab this [__] Shy Guy
[__] I think that's the game I think
that's the game oh no no no godam damn
it that was a really bad show for blue
that was real bad you're fine you're way
ahead of blue it's fine that was really
sad all right if I hadn't done my
watermelon Apple confusion which you
guys know I'm I'm Apple
dlex I can't two fruits I can't
distinguish in real life it's an apple
from a watermelon I can't do it man I
just can't how could anyone no one could
now this time I will not confuse an
apple with a watermelon remember make
promises you can't keep remember how I
said the last time that we played that
one or I wasn't even in there but I was
like who gets out on this one like
nobody only idiots only idiots get out
on that one all right this is going to
be good hey that's a good start all
right oh no oh my
God stand up stand up stand up okay oh
my God
just
please just please get out of my face
you my God get out of my way holy crap
oh God okay cross over cross over hey
what's up Mark how you doing hey what up
man oh God okay hey we're fine we're
fine man we got this God stop existing
all of you little [__] just die and
get out of my way I know right kids the
worst wo okay okay everyone just be be
chill for a moment chill be chill chill
all right I'm past the point where the
most [__] are that's is that you Bob
are you next to me right now uh I'm next
to Mark pink right yeah I'm pink okay
there's another Jelly Bean then okay oh
oh my God wait a minute
oh okay all right sorry that was mean
shouldn't have laughed at you for dying
there all right are you in second place
right now third place I don't know I
think there are some invisible people
that qualified ahead third and fourth
baby third fourth wait you got it which
one is wait wait wait wait wait wait be
patient patience my friend be careful be
careful
Donuts yep yep yep y okay yeah you got
you got you got it you got it you got it
you got it I ha you solid Victory dude
where is everybody I think a lot of them
got consumed that time yeah no joke are
we all still alive yeah we're still
alive man absolutely oh hell yeah it's
always this one it's always this why I
don't know man why is this for the
winner then too no there's got to be one
more after this okay no there's seven
okay all right this time the ultimate
chungus yep okay well oh nope not that
one definitely not that one okay but how
do you get to that
one go wait check check that out all
right all right
oh
no oh my God I like this yeah that one's
okay uh oh my God okay not the one ahead
not the one ahead he just
shook yeah I think straight go for
it yes made it no we all got murdered
[__] [__] [__] [__] die you [__]
wait did none of you make it across the
Gap no we all where's it go where's it
go where's it go where just go straight
go go
go that's uh that's a too bad for you
that's really unfortunate wait um you
going to be okay going be okay he seemed
he seemed distressed about that he
seemed very distressed
wait you all right okay buddy you okay
you okay buddy yeah oh he oh
crap
I always goof this one I literally was
the only person I saw Frozen in midair
over the finish line that wait did you
make it oh Mark's in here too I'm here
I'm here look at
that oh God
iot hey Mark hey what's up oh my God I
got knocked over oh you got to be
shooting me oh God oh God no oh God I'm
so far down I did the thing that I knew
was going to happen I went way down is
this for the all the marbles is this the
final one yeah this is the final one I
think get away from me you don't come
over
here oh the jump does not always
register no no no no no no no
pomegranates oh [__]
okay
man the jump super duper does not always
register for me right now oh nice nice
mark thank
you oh my God no not like this no God
Dam I had that so good God damn it oh my
God I'm so mad no did you get eliminated
I'm on the last level though so I stupid
stupidly
just oh my God I'm so grumbled two of
seven are gone five leave me alone you
stay on your side I'll stay on my
side oh someone's still pretty high up
on uh they running out of platforms
though they'll be down soon yeah that's
the thing about being higher up is like
when you fall boy do you
fall
oh that person no no no no no no no no
dick if they screwed
me you be kidding me Hi friend how you
doing oh
God you second to last elimination no
screw stupid pigeons [__] pigeons of
[__] from above okay I I was shocked I
went to second place because I fell
through like four of those floors at
least I'll take that one versus a tail
one any day yeah yeah that's true which
one is this this is just the get to the
other end oh it's the tubes that's right
okay M it looks like I'm in a position
to actually try the worst part of this
is the starting part honestly I wonder
if you just fall down no I did that the
first time I'm in the back screw this
noise yeah I'm not I'm in the middle but
I'm not in a place where I'm going to
succeed at this God
screw everyone on these two
no my God yeah me too okay I did not
fall thankfully okay now go oh my God
everyone's fighting each other go the
other way morons
okay yes yes yes right oh God I'm such a
sexy [__] oh okays big big swing the
door closed in my hand oh my God I
misjudged that so hard I am probably not
going to make it guys I'll see you on
the other side you coming mark I'm in
first I'm the first one AC cross I'm a
God B to me Mortals I don't want to okay
I it was the 17th one to cross and I am
still excited oh my god get away pigeon
it's always a pigeon Pig yeah it's like
a personality thing whoever picks the
pigeons is just a jerk so we're all
alive we're all good we're all good yeah
okay good yeah yeah that's the first
that's the only time I'll ever get first
place when it doesn't matter don't take
this away from you I was thrown down
into the depths of hell and I emerged to
be number one I'll take it I got balled
out of this world oh God damn it oh God
I hate the eggs all right okay so uh if
you're trying to get him out of other
people's Nest you have to sort of jump
throw them up the step and then out that
was you that devised that strategy right
yes he is jumping for a gold I'm jumping
for a gold give me gold what do I have I
have nothing I have nothing what do I
have I have I have a person I have one
of my own teammate grab this blue grab
that blue grab that blue got him got him
oh got another blue got him a he lost it
yellow's got it oh fight fight fight to
the last breath give it give it give it
give it you know what yellow you guys
have this I'll go [__] blue like
everyone else is doing okay well time
for a real champ to start [__] yellow
okay we need to definitely screw blue
because the only reason we're not losing
is that blue exists
this there's a gold coming in the middle
grab that gold I'm coming coming back
it's going to Blue oh no not blue no
it's not get it get it I'll grab
everyone around you get it get it get it
get it get it go go go get it oh my God
pick up the it it go go
oh that no Blue's got no blue come no
they do not
no get some out get some out get some
out get some out I got I get away get
him out right now oh my God I got one
out you don't do that to me blue get oh
my God go go am I being grabbed oh I got
one out we're 12 12 okay I got this go
get get get get get
get oh my God oh my God I'm literally
holding one in the air just out of the
edge of the blue basket oh my
God it's fine it's fine
fine we're
fine that was the closest back and forth
I'm sorry I think I grabbed you there
Wade at one point when you had the gold
we were all when we were all scrambling
for that gold that was so sad and then
that blue comes out of nowhere look oh
hey look a gold no one's getting it all
right I'm just going to look at all of
them cuz I'm not going to rely on doing
nothing no teamwork no teamwork here
you're all on your own just have have a
memory bananas and an orange right in
front Okay B ban Bas it's Bas don't
touch me don't touch me don't even look
at me stop it that over there by [__]
yeah you have a bunch of people around
you who are very touch grapes and
oranges okay grapes oranges bananas grap
orange and apple okay
cool yeah orange banana this is orange
hey Mark I need this hello hi let's keep
it civil let's keep it civil let's keep
iter banana apple Cherry okay so we'll
go here
wait where's grape I think I'm on a
grape oh I hope this is grape oh thank
God there was no grapes near me at all
where I was looking there were no grapes
so I trusted you yes when I have no idea
where anything is I just run to where
everyone else is running full speed I
mean if your reactions are good enough
that pretty much works yeah true you
don't even need to look it's a mango not
an apple look here the Lore Master of
fall guys over here actually it's a
mango look Mark can't even tell an apple
from a watermelon don't mangoes oh God
oh God damn it we got this BL no we're
fine we're fine we're fine we're fine we
don't be blue there's not enough of us
to interfere I think it's just six so we
got to get
this good pushes P you guys are in the
front start pushing oh I'll push going
baby
going there we go over over all right
yeah yeah yeah you want to ride down the
middle here yeah yeah yeah keep going oh
no no no no no no bad bad bad bad it's
fine it's fine it's fine just like that
we have one who's going ahead for for
interference purposes okay we need to
drift to the right to the right to the
right turn to the right to the right to
the right there we go there we go oh not
back not
back here we go here we go left left
left left hard go oh my God go go go
go got to be yellow you got to beat
yellow we we can do it we can do it push
push push no
one's go go go go go go go go go push it
push it P get it ow yes yes yes all
right we're in we're in we're in we're
in we're BL we're in let's just screw
yellow for no reason for okay no only
one disappear when we qualify apparently
oh no wait wait no it's just we did it
wow everyone just left us alone it's
it's a
miracle you right Mark breathing you're
breathing kind of weird there we're down
to the top 12 we're all three still
alive in the top
12 ground M okay this is fine this is
fine all right with three of us one of
us has to win we can do this when you
say it like that are on the front right
corner Mark we've got this I think
you're the only one not in the front row
W great oh I'm right behind you you're
behind us though that's okay cool that's
okay that's
okay yeah yeah oh I fell down like an
idiot oh God why oh God ball incoming
ball incoming oh God let me through the
Gap ball ball oh thank you sir in front
of me for taking that in the face
my god oh ball oh my God balls oh balls
oh balls oh balls balls balls no the
balls oh oh the balls oh my God J Mark
Mark you're doing good you're doing good
you're doing good I know I know I know I
know I've got this I actually have to
wait for it and then touch it okay this
is it this is it I've got this I've got
this if you miss it I'm right behind you
you got this I got it
it I'm going to count that as a win we
did ITN me too that's for us we all won
that's for us baby oh God that was
us lettuce oh my God I I saw the I saw
the crown going up again and I'm like oh
[__] not again I was right behind you I
was hoping you would miss it and
[Music]
I